[Music]
the grinch might look like a fuzzy green
beast but there's a little glimmer in
his eyes that tell us otherwise while he
might have a bone to pick with the
holidays most of us choose to give him
the benefit of the doubt after all it's
not easy being green watch until the end
to find out which color the Grinch was
supposed to be first time at the things
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a big thumbs
up now let's jump right into the
evolution of the Grinch who stole
Christmas today we will do mean things
and we will do them in style how it all
began the Grinch is a story that's been
told many times before which can make it
easy to lose sight of its original roots
believe it or not but dr. Seuss's book
How the Grinch Stole Christmas was first
released on October 12th 1957 and after
60 long years this story is still being
told the children's book tells the tale
of a cynical and maniacal character who
loves nothing more than crushing
Christmas spirit in this original
masterpiece we come face to face with a
creature who looks forward to the
holidays for very different reasons than
the who's in Whoville do instead of
spreading joy and decorating his home
with pretty lights and tinsel he roams
the streets at night to tear down
Christmas paraphernalia of any kind so
in other words this great Grouch nips
Christmas in the bud many of us believe
that How the Grinch Stole Christmas is
about the importance of celebrating the
holidays being married however this
isn't exactly the message that dr. Seuss
wanted to spread instead he wanted to
remind children and parents alike that
Christmas is becoming commercialized and
that presents have nothing to do with
the holiday season the original plot
anyone born in the 80's 90's and beyond
surely remembers the hilarious movie How
the Grinch Stole Christmas this film was
released in the year 2000 and its plot
was rewritten to welcome actor Jim
Carrey's powerful charisma while writers
and directors made sure to stay true to
dr. Seuss's original version many
changes were made however these
altercations were mostly added to
elongate the movie screen time after all
dr. Seuss's book was only 69 page
long as many of you surely remember the
Grinch's heart is two sizes too small
which makes it impossible for emotions
like love and hope to settle in as a
result the Grinch becomes a hermit who
lives in a lonely cave on Mount crumpit
it is here that he looks down at
Whoville and Spears and discussed
knowing that December 25th is quickly
approaching whenever cheerful noises
start to emanate from the city center in
this book The Grinch sneaks into the
city on Christmas Eve and steals every
last present in Whoville he dresses up
as Santa Claus and forces his dog masks
to pull a sleigh filled with gifts all
the way up to his lair unfortunately max
is unable to carry up tasks
causing the Grinch to get stranded
Midway up Mount crumpit as the Sun rises
he waits for Whoville to be filled with
cries of sorrow but instead his ears
filled with Christmas carols at this
moment he realizes that the Christmas
spirit has nothing to do with presents
causing his heart to grow three times
bigger how the grinch came to be most
writers don't like to admit it but their
main characters tend to be based off of
themselves luckily dr. Seuss is not like
most writers which is why he admitted
that the Grinch was loosely based off
with himself
however this connection was only made
after the book was written and released
on the day after Christmas dr. Seuss was
brushing his teeth when he caught a
glimpse of the Grinch in the mirror it
was then that he realized that he needed
to rediscover the meaning of Christmas
once more funny enough his very own
stepdaughter confirmed this notion when
she stated that her stepfather was the
Grinch during his sour moments and the
cat from The Cat in the Hat
during his good ones How the Grinch
Stole Christmas started as a 32 line
illustrated poem that went by the name
the who bub and the Grinch this rough
draft was published in 1955 but was
quickly revamped by dr. Seuss himself
within a few short weeks the version
that we all know and love came to life
before we move on to the next fun fact
try this one on for size dr. Seuss was
53 years old when he wrote this timeless
book and he made sure to let his readers
know that the Grinch was also 53 years
old
after all they were one in the same okay
fellow
ciao by the animated TV special How the
Grinch Stole Christmas was such a
successful book that director Chuck
Jones jumped at the chance to create a
TV special based off of its plot this 26
minute special aired on December 18th
1966 and quickly became a holiday
classic
the animated specials stayed true to dr.
Seuss's original plot which is why it
only got 26 minutes of screen time
regardless of this the special hit home
and continued to air every single year
for decades on end at the end of the
short film The Grinch risks his life to
return the stolen gifts to Whoville
causing his heart to blow up like a
balloon The Grinch gives back all the
stolen goods and gets invited in for a
holiday feast where he falls in love
with the real meaning of Christmas the
Grinch was voiced by actor Boris Karloff
who also narrated the special since the
film's been adapted many times since
most Millennials have never watched the
original special but it's never too late
to cross it off our list so if you're
feeling up to it why not kick start your
Christmas spirit by watching an
old-school animated flick watch until
the end to find out which colour the
Grinch used to be you're a mean one mr.
Grinch most of us know the song you're a
mean one mr. Grinch however we don't
have the slightest clue of where it came
from well that's all going to change as
of today because we're about to spill
the Christmas pudding the 60s were
notorious for their musical adaptations
so it shouldn't come as a surprise to
find out that the 1966 animated special
came jam-packed with three amazing songs
welcome Christmas trim up the tree and
you're a mean one mr. Grinch
we're added to the special giving it
that joyful cheer that we all know and
love
although dr. Seuss had never intended
for his children's book to become a
musical masterpiece he happily joined
the specials production and worked on
writing the classic lyrics we don't know
about you but we have a hard time
picturing how the Grinch Stole Christmas
without these timeless hits picks it up
there they'll all bring it back here
how Jim Carrey stole Christmas when dr.
Seuss created the Grinch he never once
expected his character to be interpreted
in a live-action film after all the
Grinch was a cartoon character for
crying out loud well thanks to
technological advances the 21st century
made way for many on-screen
possibilities turning into the Grinch
wasn't a natural process however which
posed a lot of problems for the
production believe it or not that
carries prosthetic makeup was so
uncomfortable that he nearly lost his
marbles in the end a Navy SEAL had to
coach poor Kerry on how to maintain his
composure despite feeling like he was
being tortured all in all carry on the
cast spent a minimum of 1,000 hours in
the makeup chair which would surely
drive anyone mad to make the movies
filming schedule worth it a bulletproof
script was written and perfected the
original plot was cast aside except for
a few key parts and a new one was
instilled this turned a 26 minute movie
into a 110 minute film and helped
amassed a total of 345 million dollars
worldwide so how does Kerry's
live-action rinche differ from the
original it quite simple really Kerry
was given full freedom to improvise his
lines and the love interest was inserted
into the plot before How the Grinch
Stole Christmas aired the Grinch had
never been in love with anyone let alone
a who from Whoville characters like
Martha May and the mayor of who-ville
were added in to give the movie more
substance on top of that the Grinch and
Cindy Lou were made to have an even
better relationship one that helped his
heart grow three times bigger oh and all
this live adaptation gave the Grinch of
that story and helped us understand how
he came to be such a cynical person
Merry Christmas mr. Burrage
[Music]
how cindy-lou helps save Christmas Cindy
Lou might have been a secondary
character in the original How the Grinch
Stole Christmas but her rule was given a
newfound purpose in the 21st century
remake in this live-action movie Cindy
takes pity on the Grinch and desperately
tries to integrate him into her
community instead of meeting him in her
home on Christmas Eve like dr. Seuss's
version so classically states she sees
him for the first time at a post office
afterward the brave little who climbs up
Mount crumpit to invite him to
who-ville's many Christmas festivities
in this film it's clear that Cindy Lou
helps the Grinch to see the holidays
through a new lens in the end it's
Cindy's determination that stops the
Grinch from stealing Christmas sure
Martha Mays love might have helped the
Grinch come around but it was little
Cindy's friendship that enlarged his
heart in the first place as the decades
go by it's clear that the Grinch is
becoming a more lovable character while
he might have scared children in the 50s
and 60s
he's lost most of his evil energy and
taken on a new light how Jim Carrey's
humor changed the way we view the Grinch
when a character has little to no
personality it's easy to make judgments
on their part for this reason many of us
thought the Grinch to be an evil being
who didn't care about anything or anyone
but himself when actor Jim Carrey dawned
on his Grinch suit however he changed
the way the world viewed this yellow
eyed monster for good directors gave
Carey full creative freedom which
allowed him to improvise his roles by
doing this he added his wit and charm to
the character making him loveable who
remembers the classic line 6:30 dinner
with me I can't cancel that again well
this is just one of those lines that
Kerry coughed up on the spot
all in all Kerry painted the Grinch in a
soirée shade and it did not make us
green with envy
instead it filled our hearts with pity
for the self loping character the latest
adaptation dr. Seuss is undying
character The Grinch will always have a
place in our hearts
which is why he's coming back to spread
some holiday cheer in 2018 the animated
film The Grinch recently hit the big
screen and its graphics are said to be
the best ones yet although the storyline
doesn't stray too far from the 1957
children's book some notable
changes were made the Grinch who is
voiced by actor Benedict Cumberbatch
catches wind that Whoville plans on
making their Christmas celebration three
times bigger than last year's which
causes the Grinch to plot against them
to successfully do so The Grinch kidnaps
a reindeer and heads to Whoville on a
sleigh where he is later confronted by
cindy-lou who wants nothing more than to
meet Santa Claus
the latest flip is loaded with new and
hilarious characters making it a must
see what the Grinch was originally
supposed to look like the Grinch we all
know and love is as green as an avocado
but in dr. Seuss's original book he was
illustrated in black and white The
Grinch also had some hints of pink and
red attached to his person however when
it came time to produce the TV special
producer and director Chuck Jones had
another idea mind after renting a car
that was painted in the most awful shade
of green he had ever seen Jones began to
envision the Grinch in the same light
after pitching the idea to dr. Seuss
Jones got the OK to change the Grinch is
furry coat from white and black to green
and it's been the same color ever since
so are you surprised to see how much the
Grinch has changed her at the last 60
years because we sure are
he definitely became more real as time
went on let us know if you've seen the
original TV special in the comments
below if not feel free to tell us which
Grinch movie was your favorite so far
we can't wait to read your comments and
that's a wrap thanks for watching and
see you next time on the things
[Music]